Maybe this is not a great example.
But I want to say if we were in the
situation, what would we we actually do?
I mean if it really is kind, if we're
doing don't boost reach for example.
What would you do to encourage me to
maybe participate in
the other nash equilibrium?
>> I guess I would just state
that's what we're going to do and
you have no reason not to do it.
>> Yeah but I'd be like I have
no reason to do it either.
>> This is true, but
since all the utilities are inside
the Matrix, might as well just do it.
>> I might as well not do it.
>> Well, you gotta do something.
>> Well, I'm going to don't boost.
>> But why?
They're both the same.
They're both 0.
I thought you wanted to make me happy?
>> That's not game theory.
Me making you happy is not game theory.
Game theory is about utilities.
So is there anything that you could
do to change the utility for me?
>> Sure.
I could offer you a banana.
>> Aha!
Could share.
Yes, and so the essence of what happens
in Cocoa Values is that we're going to
talk about making side payments.
So the punch line is going to be we're
going to do this thing that actually
benefits us mutually.
Like the sum of the payoffs is maximal.
And then we're going to
dispense the spoils.
Right, we're going to get
as many bananas as we can.
And then give them out in
a way that's fair sort of.
A priori might not be so
obvious what would be fair.
Like maybe I would say I'd hold out for
no I'm not going to give you boost
unless you give me three of the bananas.
You can keep just one.
But it's going to turn out
in this particular case that
one banana payment
actually is justifiable.
>> That's cool because
that's what I was thinking.
I was thinking,
look man I'll give you one banana.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now what if this was forty?
Would you still feel like
one banana would suffice.
>> For me?
Yeah.
>> But for
me to act to actually give you a boost?
>> I guess you would expect more.
>> Maybe more.
>> So I don't know that I
really thought this through.
But if, when the number was four like
look I can get two if I want to.
So, really this is about why
don't we split the extra benefit?
>> There, nice nice.
Okay and
that is a really powerful intuition for
understanding how these things go.
>> Okay.